author of the book six continents 15
countries 190 drinks and one mean
hangover comedian zane lamprey is
appearing at the house of blues this
friday he's appearing right now with us
via zoom zane thanks for joining us
thanks for having me kendall i
appreciate it first of all six
continents what's up antarctica i'm
assuming you just you've snubbed it
you know we tried uh
but that would have required some
military involvement and gotten very
cost prohibitive so yeah for now it's
six continents but i will do my best to
to change that in the future uh well
seriously six continents how amazing a
lot of people say you just must have the
best job in the world because you are an
alcohol expert right you you do all
things booze and tell people what's good
and what's not and you sample things all
over the world
yeah i mean i've traveled and drank in
70 71 countries 72 countries if you
count the vatican which i do uh there i
just had a little sip of wine but i'm
gonna count it right um and i've i've
done it for uh i mean i was on a show
called three sheets
um and then i did a show called drinking
mid-easy i did three seasons of that for
mark cuban's channel called hdnet which
is now called access uh and then i did
chug for nat geo which then went out to
netflix and then i did a show called
four sheets and so now i'm traveling
around the country to
breweries uh doing stand-up telling my
stories um
last year i did it uh i was at a place
called craft house brewing in henderson
uh we did two sold out shows um they
actually had to get a tent in the
parking lot and we did it out there
which was amazing and then what i did
the comedy special that i did there i
ended up shooting that as a stand-up
special which will air this fall and so
now i'm at the house of blues this
friday with a completely new hour of
comedy when you drink for for a living
kendall
you you get you end up with a lot of
stories i'm just going to put it that
way i can imagine i love the the name of
the tour then is longer than life did i
get that right log it in life exactly
right fantastic the last one was called
laughs and giraffes when i was there
last year this is now longer than life
they both have l's in them which are
difficult for people to discern the two
but this is completely new stories than
what we had last year love it and it's
very popular you have followers
literally all over the world now how did
you how did this happen how did you
stumble into this and and do we need to
do an intervention
do you know do you think you used the
word stumble intentionally or was that
just a freudian that was just
i i went to audition for a show which
was not this show and the producers are
like look we we think you're bigger than
the show that you're you're here for we
have an idea we've been kicking around
called three sheets where you travel
around the world and drink is that
something you'd be interested in doing
and i was like it's like this is a joke
yeah of course i would and so i did that
for four seasons uh then i did drinking
mid-easy for three and then chug and
then and then four sheets so i i mean
i've shot over a hundred uh episodes
i've shot in over a thousand locations
and now with this tour
uh i'm doing uh about 135 shows uh
stand-up shows at breweries exclusively
at breweries except for the house of
blues because i love that venue this is
the exception well obviously it's very
popular doing great again want to tell
people about friday night zane thanks
for joining us zane lamprey will bring
his longer than life brewery comedy tour
to the house of blues inside mandala
mandalay bay this friday should be a
great show